non j'ai pas de retour sans c'est très
étrange attends je suis comme un
streamer salut tout le monde une petite
vidéo à l'ancienne il y a Loïc Lancia
les bureaux à l'ancienne et un
ordinateur à l'ancienne parce que cet
ordinateur à 10 ans salut J'ai il y a
plein d'idées de boîtes que j'aurais
voulu lancer dans ma vie mais vraiment
j'ai un carnet avec des idées de société
de business de choses à faire avant ok
on peut pas tout faire dans la vie alors
je me suis dit plutôt que ça meurt dans
un coin Zoé je vais vous donner tu vas
nous donner
je vais vous donner cinq idées de boîtes
que vous pourriez lancer ou peut-être
pas d'ailleurs je sais pas si c'est des
bonnes idées mais ça a peut-être
stimuler votre créativité
entrepreneuriale voilà c'est une vidéo
un peu de chill un peu à l'ancienne
est-ce que mentaliste ça a des bonnes
idées de société et ben ça vous allez
savoir tout de suite
[Musique]
peut-être que je vais me lancer à Codou
ça va te donner envie dans cette
solution on trouve donc plein
d'applications genre la gestion des
relations clients vente marketing
gestion RH comptabilité évidemment
gestion de projet si une de ces
thématiques vous intéresse foncez voir
le lien dans la description n'hésitez
pas à visiter bien correctement tous
leurs sites parce que il y a un truc
intéressant chez eux c'est que la
première application que tu utilises
allez gratuitement pour toute la vie
mais non bah c'est pas mal ça en vrai
Audoux propose par exemple une solution
simple complète flexible pour la gestion
de projet qui permet à subit simple et
efficace de toutes les étapes de toutes
les tâches qui vont faire de votre
projet une réelle réelle réalisation oui
ça se dit une réelle réalisation en fait
un truc qui existe vraiment qui est
aboutit et surtout où il y a aucun oubli
et là vous vous dites oui mais ce que
odoo il permet de personnaliser des
étapes pour chacun des projets
la réponse est oui et si vous travaillez
en équipe vous vous demandez si vous
pouvez par exemple intégrer des
collaborateurs sur certaines tâches voir
est-ce que vous pouvez leur partager des
documents en temps réel sur la
plateforme ce que je peux le faire
la réponse est oui mais du coup je me
demande est-ce qu'il y a un espèce dédié
genre à la gestion des coûts des budgets
des factures la réponse bon vous avez
compris c'est ultra complet donc si vous
voulez en savoir plus sur la gestion le
suivi des projets avec Odou mais aussi
sur les autres applications qu'il
propose je vous ai mis un lien ou ça
Loïc dans la description dans la
description évidemment bien sûr toujours
la description
boîte numéro une j'ai appelé ça la
marque 99% à la base je m'étais noté un
truc l'idée c'était d'avoir une marque
qui s'appelle 100% c'est le nom de la
marque après ça va poser des problèmes
donc partons sur un arc qui s'appelle
99% et le but est très simple c'est de
favoriser une image forte de la marque
ou quand tu vois ça tu sais que sur
l'étiquette il y a pas de souci
l'étiquette elle marque 99 % de ce que
tu achètes si tu achètes du mois du jus
d'orange j'ai marqué 99 % de jus
d'orange à l'intérieur 100% ça aurait
été vraiment le goal ultime mais je me
suis aperçu en faisant des toutes
petites recherches qu'en réalité c'était
c'était pas possible il y a des
conservateurs des choses comme ça de bon
il y a des choses quand même qu'il faut
mettre dans la plupart des produits mais
tu vois un truc j'ai pas fait de
recherche donc je vais dire un peu
n'importe quoi mais genre cette marque
là qui s'appelle 99% elle peut
commercialiser n'importe quoi genre du
savon tu sais qu'il y a 99% de savon
dedans 99% tu sais que tu es sûr de la
composition c'est 99% du produit que tu
voulais acheter à la base par exemple si
tu sors des bâtonnets de crabe tu sais
les petits surimi là et ben 99%, tu sais
que c'est 99% de ça du crabe parce que
si vous voulez vous faire peur regardez
les étiquettes des Siri vous allez
vachement moins manger
société numéro 2 les laveries du
quartier
[Rires]
les laveries
non pas du tout c'est un concept il faut
que j'essaie de bien vous le vendre
parce que dans ma tête franchement si je
faisais pas ce que je fais aujourd'hui
il doit être forte chance que j'aurais
ouvert ça dans une cité un peu dense
peut-être dans un endroit un peu
étudiant comme La Rochelle par hasard
c'est un concept de la vrille mais
vraiment très cosy donc déjà il y a de
l'espace quand tu arrives limite il y a
un parking tu peux venir en voiture etc
c'est facile si c'était en province et
que c'est un petit peu loin de là où tu
es bon en tout cas dites-vous que il y a
de l'espace c'est cosy il y a des tables
il y a des chaises mais il y a des
tables et des chaises en mode de sympa
tu vois du style une petite table ronde
avec 4 5 chaises et puis une autre table
ronde mais dépareillés avec des chaises
dépareillés tu vois ambiance un peu un
peu Bordeaux autour de moi tu vois un
truc un peu un peu un peu Speakeasy dans
le fond si vous connaissez pas des
Speakeasy ce sont des barres cachés
d'ailleurs tu vois ça boucle la boucle
parce que à Paris elle se trouve
derrière une machine à laver dans une
laverie embarque et que je connais pas
et tu connais pas l'idée c'est que comme
dans certains coworking où tu payes à
l'heure des espèces de cowork ou tu
payes à l'heure et d'accès à des
viennoiseries à des boissons etc mais là
c'est pareil tu paies alors tes machines
ça c'est autre chose tu peux les
machines comme dans n'importe quel
laverie mais pour rester dans la laverie
tu paies à l'heure donc quelques euros
qui te donnent accès à plein de surfs il
y a pas d'alcool c'est que des boissons
chaudes des fraîches peut-être des thés
glacés maison des trucs comme ça des
petits biscuits des trucs tu as le droit
de consommer un petit peu comme tu veux
et de somme forfaitaire toi aussi axé à
un très bon réseau wifi tant qu'à faire
dans mon imaginaire les machines à laver
elles sont derrière une cloison donc il
y a une cloison un peu insonorisée tu
vois et tu as tout le système des
machines et des sèche-linge qui sont qui
sont derrière comme ça t'es pas accaparé
par le bruit et là tu vas te dire oui
bon ok pourquoi pas peut-être que ça
existe déjà mais non mais l'idéal va
plus loin c'est que ce que je voudrais
c'est que dans cette ce concept la
laverie du quartier il y a une espèce de
dece qu'un bureau comme ça dans le fond
mais un peu ambiance vieille hôtel si
vous avez déjà fait la Tour de la
Terreur à c'est un peu cette ambiance là
dans ma tête donc un desk avec une
personne derrière sur ce deck il y a le
petit ping sur lequel tu peux appuyer et
tout et au-dessus de la personne il y a
un écran un peu comme tu as dans les
gares avec le numéro de machine et leur
disponibilité ou le temps qu'il reste
oui bonjour vous désirez Loïc donc sur
l'écran il y aurait les machines
disponibles le temps qui reste avant
chaque machine avant chaque sèche-linge
peut-être même il y aurait des applis ah
ouais des machines je sais pas mais en
tout cas depuis ta place tu vois ça
évidemment tout autour sur les murs il y
a des bouquins des jeux de société des
jeux de rôle etc qui sont en libre accès
à disposition et ce qui permettrait de
faire ça l'abri comme ça à plusieurs tu
viens tu fais ton linge tu fais tes
petits draps tu fais ton petit séchage
en même temps tu fais des petits jeux tu
bois des soft accès au réseau c'est
quand même stylé et là vous vous dites
mais je suis sûr qu'on peut aller encore
plus loin je suis d'accord avec vous on
peut aller loin alors je prends mes
notes l'idée c'était qu'il y a des
services ils sont accessibles au
comptoir sert à ça là aussi la personne
qui est là il y aurait la formule je
m'occupe de tout donc là c'est tu donnes
à la personne et tes facturé au kilo et
la personne elle s'occupe de laver ton
linge de le mettre à sécher de le plier
alors faudrait peut-être revenir le
lendemain pour aller le chercher après
ça ça dépend on s'organise des services
de repassage pareil tu laisses ton linge
toi tu le laves toi-même mais il doit se
faire plier et repasser et tu repasses
le lendemain on passe le chercher ton
linge repasser retouche service de
retouche sur rendez-vous mais il y a
même plus que ça en fait dans ma tête il
y a forcément des heures creuses dans
les laveries ou le soir ou les trucs
comme ça ou tu peux organiser des
événements j'avais un événement ou
franchement quand j'étais plus jeune je
m'y serais inscrit l'événement
j'apprends à retoucher mes vêtements
j'apprends à recoudre un petit truc qui
s'est déchiré où j'apprends j'apprends à
coudre un bouton c'est pas mal ça tu
sais coudre Loïc pas du tout et s'il y
avait ce service dans une laverie un peu
cosy ambiance il achète j'ai votre
premier client les gars alors bon là là
il est bien mais s'il était pas bien et
que j'allais dans ton truc ben je
l'aurais fait faire direct non mais
c'est pas la vidéo
idée numéro 3 ça s'appelle mon
brainstorm c'est le nom de code vous
pouvez changer le nom si vous reprenez
l'idée si vous reprenez une de mes idées
je vous en supplie vous m'invitez à
l'inauguration vous m'envoyez des photos
des trucs je veux savoir mon brainstorm
l'idée de cette société c'est que à
l'organisme des brainstorm selon votre
budget dit comme ça c'est pas ouf mais
vous allez voir toi tu donnes ton thème
donc tu appelles mon brainstorm tu
donnes ton thème tu dis le nombre de
personnes qui faudrait étudier un peu
voilà l'univers de ce sur quoi tu as
besoin de brainstormay et ton budget tu
dis également le degré de compétence que
tu veux de chaque personne sur la
thématique par exemple si tu veux ouvrir
un restaurant peut-être que tu as besoin
d'avoir un chef qui a déjà eu un ou deux
restaurants tu vois mais peut-être aussi
tu veux des personnes qui sont des
clients des simples clients qui font
beaucoup de restaurants tu vois tu tu
peux prendre des personnes d'univers
différents autour de la thématique avec
leur degré de compétences dans cette
thématique évidemment mon brainstorm
s'occupe de te trouver ces personnes là
dans leur formule GOLD on va dire de te
trouver le lieu etc de t'organiser ça
pour que tu puisses brainstorm brains
alors évidemment c'est à toi de mener
cette réunion là et les idées qui sont
échangées appartiennent à la personne
qui a fait faire le brainstorm à ce
moment-là évidemment mais on peut le
développer en vrai sous forme d'applis
j'ai bien réfléchi on peut faire une
applique qui s'appelle membrane Storm ou
tu peux t'inscrire en tant que
consultant qui ben voilà moi je
m'appelle Fabien licat j'ai des
compétences dans le domaine du spectacle
vivant j'ai des compétences dans le
domaine de la vidéo de l'écriture de
livre du mentaliste mais tu peux aussi
t'inscrire en tant que client et dans
ces cas-là tu dis bah tiens je veux
monter un spectacle j'aimerais bien en
discuter avec des personnes qui ont
l'habitude de faire des spectacles ou
qui se sont autoproduits ou qui font du
mentalisme etc et hop tu me sélectionnes
dedans parce que je suis disponible il y
a mes tarifs etc etc et donc tu te
montres comme ça le brainstorm donc en
vrai tu es à la fois client et à la fois
prestataire parce que ça vaut le coup de
s'inscrire à chaque fois dans les deux
et ça permet de les faire après soit en
visio soit dans un lieu physique qui
réservable aussi bien l'application il
peut y avoir je sais pas moi un
partenariat avec cocoon qui qui loue des
lieux comme ça de manière autonome mais
je pense que vous comprenez le concept
de ça et pourquoi j'ai pensé à ça parce
que moi j'ai souvent besoin de ça j'ai
souvent besoin d'échanger avec des
personnes en miroir c'est surtout moi
qui ai besoin de parler et de croiser
mes idées mais j'ai besoin d'avoir en
face de moi des personnes qui ont un
avis ou qui ont une compétence ou qui
ont un regard tout neuf parce que
justement ils ont zéro compétences dans
le domaine et c'est extrêmement
stimulant je pense que sous forme
d'appli ça pourrait être intéressant
après avoir à quel public ça s'adresse
mais je trouvais que c'était une bonne
idée en tout cas assez bonne pour vous
en parler
quatrième idée ça s'appelle mon voisin
est là pareil c'est un nom de code vous
pouvez trouver un meilleur nom à ça
alors ça c'est plus pour les personnes
qui habitent en ville ou dans des en
tout cas des bâtiments où il y a
plusieurs personnes l'idée ce serait
d'avoir une application qui pourrait
marcher au bâtiment ou à la rue ça se
trouve c'est ça existe déjà j'en ai pas
entendu parler la comète était pas bonne
les gars fait un bon brainstorm pour
revoir votre communication CF la boîte
précédente donc comme son nom l'indique
ce serait une appli de service entre
voisins où on pourrait mettre des
services à disposition par exemple je
suis chez moi toute la journée je peux
réceptionner vos colis pour ces 15
prochains jours par exemple et à chaque
fois que tu fais une action faut
toujours passer par l'appli tu marques
des points alors ça ça définit est-ce
que tu marques des des points qui te
permettent d'avoir des sous et l'appli
est payante ou est-ce que tu marques des
points qui sont transformables après en
bon cadeau sur l'application tu vois je
sais pas il y a un modèle économique à
définir tout tout ça est possible et
tout ça et à voir mais voilà ça peut
être donc je disais pour faire des
courses pour garder les chiens pour
garder les chats pour réceptionner un
colis pour menu travaux pourquoi pas
pour se prêter du matériel je n'ai pas
de perceuse hop sur mon voisin est là
tiens j'ai un voisin Loïc Loïc est-ce
que tu aimes perceuse
tu me la prêtes s'il te plaît oui bah tu
vois ces deux points de me la prêter
mais en même temps si tu veux je
réceptionne ton colis cette semaine donc
tu m'avais parlé ces deux points aussi
et voilà de nom donnant service des
changes de toute manière peut-être même
après on peut se passer de l'appli une
fois qu'on rencontre bien ses voisins
c'est possible mais moi qui fait
beaucoup de bâtiments dans de grandes
villes faut pas croire qu'on connait
vraiment nos voisins on sait jamais qui
a derrière l'oeil de bœuf
voilà ça peut être bien aussi pour
ramasser le courrier pour les plantes
pour pour les déménagements aussi les
déménagements les emménagements parce
que si on le porte à l'échelle de la rue
entière là ça commence à faire du monde
parce qu'on sait que c'est dur
d'implanter des services comme ça dans
juste un bâtiment
cinquième société que j'avais dans ma
tête que j'ai jamais créé mais vous
pourriez créer et petite spoil petit
spoil Loïc en fait sur un bonus il y a
une boîte en plus je me demandais si
j'allais vous en parler mais je la
trouve marrante alors là c'est un lieu
on est deux nouveaux dans
l'investissement immobilier comment on
appelle ça
de tout ce qui est est-ce que est-ce que
vous avez un patrimoine Gnagna
que j'ai appelé ça c'est un lieu où tu
viens travailler tranquille et là c'est
sûr il y en a qui se dit mais c'est
vraiment un truc de Bobo de voir besoin
d'un lieu pour travailler tranquille oui
mais le lieu serait principaux et il y a
il y a un truc dans la démarche
psychologique ou quand tu vas là-bas tu
te fais un peu une promesse à toi-même
tu sais c'est un peu comme quand tu vas
chez le psy le fait de payer on dit que
ça ça entame déjà la thérapie mais là
c'est pareil le fait d'aller payer pour
aller au deepwork tu sais que pas le
temps de niaiser quoi tu vas pas aller
là-bas pour jouer avec ton téléphone ou
sinon ça n'a aucun intérêt donc c'est
pour participer dans cette démarche
évidemment l'environnement est sympa ce
qui pourrait être cool c'est que quand
tu arrives tu dois donner ton objectif
pourquoi tu es là alors on va pas se la
faire à Victor Hugo mais tiens il pourra
y avoir le storytelling de Victor Hugo
d'ailleurs là-bas Victor Hugo pour
écrire les Les Misérables il y arrivait
pas que il était plutôt procrastinateur
et du coup il avait trouvé une technique
il donnait tous ses vêtements à ses à
son personnel de maison qui partait avec
il lui disait pas où était ses fringues
et Victor Hugo n'avait de pas accès à
ses vêtements que si leur présentait un
chapitre terminé et c'est comme ça qu'il
se forçait à écrire alors évidemment
chez deepwork on va pas bosser à poil
c'est tout nu toi tu t'ennuies toi tu es
un enfant toi mais tu arrives tu donnes
ton objectif en arrivant et tu donnes
une manière de de quantifier de pouvoir
prouver en partant que tu as terminé
alors évidemment il y a une faille vous
la voyez tout de suite tu peux mentir en
fait et la personne elle est pas là pour
rentrer justement dans le détail de ce
que tu as fait ou pas mais c'est juste
pour te mettre une scène pression à
toi-même en fait il doit lui donner un
élément tangible en partant pour dire
ouais ouais c'est bon j'ai réussi je
suis content etc évidemment en arrivant
là-bas tu aurais une boîte dans laquelle
aussi tu peux laisser ton téléphone si
tu en as pas besoin pour faire ce
deepwork là tu pourras aussi avoir accès
à des ordinateurs qui sont à disposition
qui n'ont pas de connexion à Internet si
tu as pas besoin d'être connecté à
Internet pour le travail que tu es venu
faire tu vois ce serait comme ça un
environnement vraiment très sain et
quand tu vas là-bas tu sais que tu vas
accomplir quelque chose si tu vas là-bas
pour une demi-journée tu vas avec ton
objectif précis tu ressors c'est sûr
qu'il est réalisé et ce sera un truc
très motivant parce qu'en plus très
entouré de personnes comme ça avec une
petite salle de pause pourquoi pas pour
échanger
voici donc
ce qui était mais j'avais dit qu'il y en
aura une sixième donc il y en a il y en
a une sixième que j'aime bien viens on
va la faire ensemble je vais te la
pitcher tu me dis si tu investis dans
mon projet Loïc
attention je vais faire tourner le siège
très vite ça va t'aspirer
salut bienvenue
test je teste ta formation.com ok waouh
je crois que c'était genre testa
fidélité ou des trucs comme ça
tout de suite salut ok toi tu veux aller
à la fête foraine avec moi ou pas
donc testeur de formation c'est une
applique qui testerait des formations
pour toi c'est toutes les formations la
97 euros les trucs qui machin et tout en
fait tu vas sur cette applique tu paies
20 % de cette formation ouais mais alors
imagine c'est les formations à 3000
balles attends mais c'est bien hein
de la formation et on te donne une
évaluation alors révélation c'est dans
la formation quel pourcentage en gros de
la formation est trouvable sur le net tu
vois c'est quoi la qualité du produit la
qualité de la forme la durée est-ce
qu'il y a un vrai parcours pédagogique
est-ce que tu retiens tu reçois juste un
lien Dropbox et un canal télégram tu
vois tu vois vraiment ce que tu trouves
dedans tu reçois une synthèse si la
formation est déjà référencée depuis
moins d'un an sur l'application tu ne
paies que 10% pour avoir cette
information là pas mal
et si par contre toi tu as payé les 20%
tel feedback de de l'application tu dis
c'est OK j'achète la formation tu
l'achètes tu envoies la preuve d'achat
et on te rembourse la moitié de ce que
tu as versé donc tu auras payé que 10 %.
mais par contre on considère que si tu
l'achètes pas ok tu as pas perdu les 20
% que tu as donné tu as économiser les
80 % que tu as pas donné pour pas te
faire avoir donc ça reste rentable
il y a pas mal de trucs à trouver déjà
pour que l'appli elle puisse acheter
toutes ces formations et que les
personnes elles puissent le tester mais
ça me paraît faisable un système aussi
qui permettrait de contourner les petits
malins qui vont sortir 10 formations par
semaine juste pour demander à l'appli de
les acheter de les tester parce que là
il y a une faille dans ce côté là c'est
bien que les trouver la faille
directement parce que j'allais dire ça
mais mais aussi l'appli elle pourrait
refuser tu vois certaines formations
faudrait qu'il y ait peut-être avec tes
référencesment Google ou quoi de se
rendre compte que ok il y a une
attractivité pour cette formation les
gens se demandent etc quoi pas mais
c'est pas mal on pourrait mettre aussi
des avis clients des formations
à force de voir les formations de
partout là
en plus sur le prince je suis pas contre
les formations j'en ai acheté plusieurs
et tout je trouve ça très utile et tout
mais maintenant il y en a tellement ce
moment il y a toutes les formations pour
les monteurs tu les vois ou pas passer
et ça et ça et ça et ça achète ma forme
et c'est ça se trouve la formation elle
est très bonne tu vois il y en a une il
y a de même il y en a une que je vois
passer qui a l'air pas mal en tout cas
j'aime bien ce monteur et je me dis si
Astro va les canons sa formation super
bien et je peux pas te dire pourquoi tu
peux voir eh ben je sais pas ça se fait
pas tu es une sacrée trésorerie quand
même oui je me fais un business model la
deuxième chose j'essaie de trouver
quelques formations un peu à la mode des
trucs que je vois beaucoup dans les pubs
etc et je les achète donc j'investis
dessus c'est quelques centaines d'euros
ou peut-être un millier d'euros tu vois
je fais vraiment le retour là-dessus tu
vois de ce qu'elle va aller etc et je le
mets en libre-service sur l'application
sur le site et de là je réinvestis
encore quelques centaines ou milliers
d'euros pour faire de la publicité sur
les mêmes canaux ou la pub passe pour la
formation et de dire vous demandez si
cette formation vaut le coup consultez
gratuitement sur notre site et je fais
un petit appel comme ça pour faire
connaître tu vois je vois bien la pub
vous avez déjà vu cette formation vous
voulez savoir si ça vaut le coup et bien
justement à combien de pourcentage est
directement retrouvé sur le net
qu'est-ce que vous retrouverez vraiment
y a-t-il un parcours pédagogique est-ce
que je crois que c'était le nom de
l'application je fais c'est un peu long
quand même ça vous fait quand même du
taf ça vous fait six entreprises comme
ça monter tu avais une idée de boîte toi
monte c'est une boîte on peut mettre des
petits oiseaux pour qu'ils puissent
vivre bien ok merci Loïc et merci Fabien
et merci surtout au doux d'avoir
sponsorisé cette vidéo vous pouvez
découvrir leurs services via le lien qui
est dans la description vous avez tout
le détail de tout ça dedans
abonnez-vous à cette chaîne je m'appelle
toujours fabianica il s'appelle toujours
Loïc Lagarde toujours Mentalist il est
toujours menteur très bien je sais pas
pourquoi je sais c'est bien aimé parce
que j'aime pas les gens
à très bientôt Ciao